un pays organisateur on joue comme sinon
on n' pas envie de jouer si vous ne
voulez pas mouer le maillot pour
l'équipe de Côte d'Ivoire restez chez
vous une seule une seule victoire deux
défaites non vraiment c'est c'est un
million c'est c'est c'est un Milon
vraiment pourquoi tu es jaloux de lu
jalousie jaloux JAL on gagne ù on gagne
nous ne sommes même pas stressés parce
qu'on va les gagner tout à l'heure il y
a pas de problème pas de souci bon je
dirais 2- 2 pour la Côte d'Ivoire
aujourd'hui on va sans problème et on va
se
qualifier compliqué mais bon tout est
[Applaudissements]
possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'attends pas la fin du mois par je
suis découragé maman je suis découragé
Côte d'Ivoire là c'est quand on met
notre cœur sur que nous déçoit c'est
jamais vu c'est la honte l' honte
nationale nous sommes à la place que
nous méritons cette équipe manquit de
tout et de tout même si par miracle
on passe par le système de meilleur 3e
mais cette équipe ne mérite pas d'aller
plus
loin onattendait pas ça 4 but
à0 nous Chion équipe d'arique me notre
jou
deco a segir con la Humildad con la
ilusión a pensar losav de
final